you should undo your dadgum budget maybe
for the first time in your life put your
income for the month at the top of the
page and then give every dollar an
assignment I will promise you two things
will happen number one thing will happen
is that you will feel like you got a
raise because you will go where is all
this freaking money going
it's gonna blow your mind how much you
waste
and the second thing that's going to
happen is you're going to get a sense of
Peace instead of a sense of anxiety even
though you've actually done nothing with
money yet
now you've actually executed a plan that
says if I take these 17 steps I'm going
to be free
and as soon as you see the steps in
front of you then you realize they're
doable your anxiety goes down your uh
stress level goes down your peace level
goes up and you kind of just slick your
hair back and go okay let's get about
the business of doing this